welcome back to truth news we're
celebrating our own deborah norville day
i'm with the incredible job
and i love this you know how like
there's so many fun things to celebrate
and holidays now that we okay so guess
what this is every day's a holiday
and this is a really good holiday and
this is a really good holiday you're
absolutely right what holiday is it is
national pizza day and maybe you could
tell from the table here my favorite day
oh drew you know okay i got to take this
off i feel so silly i wouldn't even wear
a veil when i got married really yeah i
looked just ridiculous
you do look really sexy in it though i'm
telling you um well ross i want to know
is it scientifically true
that pizza is proven
to make us happy is this a fact i am
going to say yes it is a fact and it
actually does come uh from a scientific
study slice says uh the smell of pizza
actually does make us happy i don't need
a scientist to tell me that by the way
even just thinking about pizza releases
something called dopamine in you which
makes you happy and when you bite into
that slice carbs will actually give you
a boost of serotonin so scientists said
i can eat pizza today thank you very
much
why do i think a pizza person did that
study
i don't care who did i totally support
it by the way i'm buying all those facts
all right well let's dig in um we've got
an eight-foot mama from big a bite right
here in new york city
this is such a thing of beauty i can't
thank them enough for providing us with
this pizza now you are a chicago i am
and i recognized it before the food
person even confirmed this is a chicago
deep dish pizza from lou malnati so i'm
gonna show you right here
a test i was standing here it slid in
and deborah goes illuminati's yeah wow
um
can you see this cheese on this one that
i'm pulling off like it's warm
hi you're going to be in my tummy
hi
and this is from buddies in detroit this
is called a detroit style pizza they do
it square and i love detroit and look at
this the coolest um
cutter
cute how cute is that and show yours
yours is even cuter is this a cutter
this is a cutter look at that guys it's
a it's a
bicycle
so you can cut your pieces with the
bicycles you can just still be a little
drive it across there yeah
and back it up over that away this is a
really great idea
okay am i supposed to be doing anything
because all i'm doing you lost me
putting my face in here i'm like oh gosh
i am at work but i literally i had that
moment where i was like
well the great thing about pizza
is you can order it and be happy you can
make it home and be happy
and that's what happy looks like
so i have a question for you where do
you lie on hawaiian pizza like the um
pineapple i would never
that's just
no offense sorry lovely people of hawaii
but i don't think you put a pineapple on
a pizza it's just a personal thing see
i'm okay with it i like it are you
eating it no you're not i wasn't but i
will now deborah just to make a point
i am shockingly you know how we are so
different at times ross i am on the
pineapple express really
do you know what because you're so
encouraging drew oh there she goes we're
going to do a little taste test
i'm going to do it confront my fears
and here we go
meh okay
but you tried i tried ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
i'll catch her every weekday on inside
edition
or on your youtube channel with the 18
billion views
[Music]
you